we introduced these two results we
bought them from the double angle
formula for 10 that's kind of the route
of where they came from and then we use
the double angle formula for sine and
cosine to say that if you've got if you
let T equal this okay then you can have
expressions for sine x cos x tan x all
in terms of this team babe and it turns
it all into algebra which is really nice
okay we started by looking at suppose
some identities that you could've solved
even without knowing this but now we're
gonna cross over into a space where it's
like well what would you do with this
thing
have you seen you've seen trig equations
like this before but critically this is
a really big deal
did you usually see something like this
now that little - that's square right
that changes everything
if it was square what would you do will
be a first step you're good so this
thing here sides where you use the
Pythagorean identity and you'd go 1
minus cos squared and it's all in terms
of cosines you can just go from there
okay so it's thumbs up but um we don't
have a square okay we just have this so
what are we gonna do with it what might
be another strategy cos try well what
might you try yeah yeah okay divided by
cosine is not a bad idea because it's
one of the main strategies we use when
you see more mixed up together we want
to turn things into tens right that's
generally a good idea except run into a
problem right what power of course I
would you like to divide by one there's
nothing squared is you'd been wrong turn
that into ten turn them so just one well
you - nice - and then this would turn
into sec - see you sort of in the same
problem that you were with in the
beginning right I don't have anything
squared I'm kind of in trouble
right perhaps ah I can't so glad you
mentioned that now I'm gonna show you of
the suggestions we've taken this is the
best one so far but still got problems
will I will pursue it at the end what
would it look like if I swear everything
okay well let's have a look okay um this
is going to become nine sine squared X
minus twelve sine X cos x + +4 cos
square ya equals one that makes sense
did you see my daughter can square both
sides now this thing I can work this
thing I can work with and you can get
some solutions out of this but it's not
perfect it's not perfect okay because I
can get some solutions out of it
in fact I can get too many solutions out
of it let's just let me give you a
trivial example suppose I gave you an
equation like this hmm what's the
solution to this equation
okay well it's just there but now look
if I do the same thing there that I did
here square both sides I have added
solutions right you can see like it's
nothing mathematically wrong from here
to here but this thing has solutions
that this doesn't okay
so eventually I get well I get two
solutions here and then I have to test
them out here to see if they actually
work with my original equation okay you
can't do that you can't do that and it
works fine but we have a tool at our
disposal that we can use to avoid that
okay so let's try this right I want to
leave this aside for a little bit you
can you can pursue it if you like it
does work okay but instead we're gonna
try this new technique that we've got
okay so if I want to use t result what's
the first thing I have to say so
Rarity's they haven't defined t for you
so I should have to find a domain by the
way
let's go north to 360 that's pretty
standard okay so I'm going to introduce
T and then I can start working with this
thing okay so sine X and cos x if you
like you can draw your triangle if your
theta there and by definition you
two T 1 minus T squared 1 plus T squared
if that helps you remember what sine and
cos should be okay so I'm gonna have
three times which one is it
opposite hypotenuse right so every two T
on 1 plus T squared
yep - 2 lots of off okay which ones
cosine maybe 1 minus T squared on 1 plus
T spoon yeah this is the this is the big
messy okay and that's equal to 1
okay so I've done my substitution all is
well what might be the most helpful
quickest most efficient way to simplify
this algebraic mistake I've got 1 plus T
Square here and 1 plus T Square there
okay so I could roll it together in one
big fraction that were just fine
but I'm gonna save myself the effort
because if I put that all together
somebody's gonna have to come over this
right-hand side isn't it
right so I'm gonna get saved in our days
I'm just gonna multiply through okay by
1 plus T squared that means on the right
hand side I'll have 1 plus T squared
okay and then here the demand is to just
disappear so here I've got a CT right
yeah just watch out for your double
negative see it looks to me like I've
got minus 2 plus 2 T squared happy okay
this is really good you see this is the
whole point I've got algebra now right
this is just a quadratic this is great I
can solve this let's get it all on one
side and then we'll work from there okay
so go t square there and I'll go two of
them there so that'll leave me with just
one insight I'll do my teacher next and
then what will my constants be good ok
so it's not very nice
doesn't really factorize like you know
just off the bat there's gonna be
something irrational here so that's fine
let's just dive into it right T is going
to be equal to minus 6 plus or minus
square root of 6 plus 12
all over - yeah happy keep going a
little bit minus six plus or minus the
square root of 48 what's the biggest
square you can pull out a 48 and 16 it
looks like to me excuse me so that's
gonna be a 4 on the outside square root
of 16 and that'll leave a 3 underneath
the radical sign on - so now I can
actually get rid of my fraction that's
gonna be minus 3 plus or minus 2 root 3
that's what T Z so now I have gotten to
the end of where my algebra can take me
I haven't T equals this so now I should
bring back what T is actually equal to
tan X on soo right is minus 3 plus 3
okay so this bridge is out doesn't it
this is this is two different things
12 into 1 right so it's 10 X on 2 is
equal to this and 10 X on 2 is equal to
this okay now before we go any further I
want to think about what this is equal
to right you're gonna obviously have to
use your calculator like this is some
lawfulness know exactly who's going on
here okay but before we go there I just
want you to know what happened here
and what it means for this right I'm no
longer solving in terms of X I'm solving
in terms of X on - okay
so therefore when I solve for this my
domain is a little bit different isn't
it do you remember when we were mucking
around with domain with different
functions right if everything is in
terms of X on twos so this is the domain
for X what I have to do this to change
it to a domain of pixel - just / - right
/ - it's because if I want to turn this
into an X on to
and I better turn this Intel into it I
guess for the kids I should do that on
so forth
okay so therefore my real domain when
I'm solving these guys I just put it on
the side
my real debate is from naught to 180
that's a little unusual but that's what
we're working with okay right so now at
this point get your calculator up pop in
Tan inverse and then see what you get
you should get two angles
I've got X on two is equal to now um
normally they'd say minutes and seconds
and so on
I'm not that fast I just want to
demonstrate the principle to you so if
I've got this right I've got something
like ninety eight point seven nine blah
blah blah blah is that right is that
what you're getting yeah okay over here
I'm getting something smaller okay is
that checking out are you getting the
right values yes yes thumbs up okay good
seeing month that's good now remember
how I said look I don't mean for X on to
is from naught to 180 so this is really
helpful here because at this point we
would usually say are there any more
solutions right and if we were from
naught to 360 we would say yes ten is
periodic every 180 degrees and B copy
every 180 is so you'd say this plus 180
and that gives you another solution but
because we're using T result result
divided by 2 if I hadn't won into this
I'd go outside my domain if I add one of
you to this in fact if I had 180 to
anything because my domain is only 180
degrees long I'm gonna go outside the
domain so these are my two solutions for
excellence - yeah okay thank you I might
as well mention that to everyone okay so
when here when you punch in this and
then you're telling us to be at minus 81
something minus eighty one point blah
blah blah blah okay but look look this
which is what your calculators hanging
this is outside of domain right so you
add 180 that's how I got this angle
yeah hundred need to get inside the
domain because 10 is periodic every
hundred eighty degrees okay
all right now that's very nice we have
solution to X on to what our original
equation it's not in terms of X onto so
from these two I'm going to multiply by
2 and that'll give me two solutions for
X so I'm getting this he's what I
prepared earlier I'm gonna check the
rounding on that one I'm not sure you
would normally do this two degrees and
minutes probably but I'm not I'm not
interested in like your accuracy I'm
just interested in you seeing the
progression of the solution okay so now
this is my solution I'm done
not bad hey you took this thing right
which is kind of like the current
methods that we have just kind of
attorney on empty I'm taking this all
and we're gonna make things worse by
like sparing everything out you get four
solutions you get these two and then you
get two months and you have to test you
have to take all four values that you
get chuck them in there some work and
some what okay in fact some will be
exactly negative of that of 1 you get
minus one it weren't evaluate properly
and you say they're not solutions